hello everyone and welcome to round four
of this year's Super bet chess classic
it's a very nice game between bogda and
Daniel dayak and dalireza firozan and
the problem of being a 2700 player in a
super event such as this one is that
even if you're 2700 and you're a really
strong player uh you're still the Bottom
seed and everyone will try their
absolute best
um at the beat you no one will give you
a draw if it's a fairly equal possession
everyone will just play it out as they
of course they are expecting they are
better than you on the other hand uh
dark is much lower rated than alireza so
if he beats him he will get a whole lot
of points uh to improve his classical
rating so let's see what happens in this
one and uh well as the title suggests uh
a a bluff definitely happens so here we
have pointed the four Ponte D5 Knight to
F3 Knight to F6 and now Pawn to C4 we
have C6 the slab defense uh and pawn to
E3 Knight to C3 is the absolute Main
Line we have on the E3 the so-called
quiet variation and Bishop to F5 by
others are preparing E6 and then usually
white just goes after the bishop praised
the bishop for Knight and um you know
the game continues but here we ignite
the C3 E6 and now not Knight stage four
which is by far the most played move in
the position here uh Bogan and Daniel
played Bishop to E2 and okay uh alvareza
says uh it's uh definitely some sort of
a line aimed at um uh throwing me out of
my opening knowledge uh so he just plays
the principle H6 uh now Knight to H4
doesn't really do all that much because
you can tuck the bishop back to
H7 and he says all right show me what
this is all about we have castles Knight
beat the D7 and now uh usually people
continue with B3 then you think get to
the dark score Bishop but here we have
Bishop back to D3 and it seems like a
loss of a Tempo First bishop E2 then
Bishop to D3 but again uh he did prepare
this for all it is uh let's see what he
had in mind Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Bishop to B4 just
continuing development we have Bishop to
D2 and now there are some moves where uh
games where A5 was played Bishop
captures and C3 is a normal move also
Queen to B6 but here there is a place
Bishop to A5 and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game
uh so here we have Pawn to B4 uh asking
alireza are you maybe interested in in a
nice B4 Pawn but of course if you take
it then I'm gonna play Knight captures
and D5 Now open up an attack on your
Bishop that's a weird Arrow sorry any
Bishop captures on D2 you're gonna
capture here with check first and only
then capture Back and You're Gonna
eliminate a very strong Central Pawn
here so of course all it is it just goes
back Bishop to C7 he wants to use the
bishop later on to attack the white king
uh Pawn to B5 and now just Knights the
B6 putting pressure on the C4 pawn and
now you could consider something like C5
let's say ignite the C4 maybe even a A4
to create a
a very strong setup on the queen side
such as this but instead we have B
captures and C6 oh it is a place D
counters and C4 and now Queen back the
C2 so upon sacrifice uh by uh the ACT uh
sort of messed up a little as a spawn
structure now the C pawns are weak and
he will of course uh put the Rooks on
the C file and go after those pawns if
he can take both of them then he is the
one who is going to be up upon so here
we have Knights day four uh but only
this just ignores it he castles we have
Rook 8 to C1 and now Queen to D5 for the
moment still defending the D5 Pawn uh
Bishop to B4 attacking The Rook we have
Rook F to B8 and now Knight to B2
putting pressure on the C4 Pawn but now
upon the A5 chases away the bishop
Bishop to A3 and now even Pawn to C3 all
it is it says if you capture my Pawn now
I'm gonna capture your opponent A2 and
I'm still gonna be up a pawn so here we
have Knight back to D3 and now Knight
the E4 for the moment defending the C3
upon and Knight the C5 trying to kick
away alirez's knight from E4 and then
finally win back his pawn and alireza
now allows at Knight the D2 Knight
captures on D2 captures Queen captures
and now Ponte E5 so this is a a clear
example of what to do if someone
sacrifices a pawn in order to sort of
mess up your Pawn structure to create
more weaknesses to attack later on uh
you will try to give back material at
the exact moment when it serves you the
most then this is where it serves as the
most uh as of course now captures is
impossible the queen on D2 would would
be hanging so Pawn to E4 chasing away
the queen and queen all the way back to
d8 he doesn't capture on D4 later on in
the game alireza said that this was sort
of a bluff that he thought that Queen
captures on D4 was the best move but as
booked and Daniel was much lower on time
he decided to keep the game going and uh
you know hope for a mistake so here Rook
after D1 and now he captures on D4 we
have Queen captures and now Bishop to F4
and no sorry this is where alireza said
that he sort of bluffed this because uh
I mean what do you play this
uh if you trade Queens which of course
you can let's say Captain's captors now
even trade a rook zero captures with
chakra capture 78 uh eurok is hanging
how do you defend if you play Rook to B1
you attack the Knight Knight C4 and the
white can pretty much resign there's no
square for the bishop yeah if you put
the bishop on C1 then just Rook the D1
with check if you if you put it on B2
then you can just capture and again Rook
the D1 check wins the game so it's very
hard to to figure out what to do with
the group to be Rook to B1 is impossible
Rook the E1 can be played but then okay
Knight to C4 and it's still very hard
for white to play this so obviously
Queen capture 78 is impossible uh what
you should do is something like Queen to
C3 but the point was that the dock was
very low on time and he wanted that to
spend as much time here as possible he
didn't go for Queen to C3 he played Rook
the C2 instead just getting the Rook out
of Harm's Way and now Queen to G5 again
just uh making an active move and what
is what is happening here we have rooked
F1 and now Rook the d8 trying to win
some open files with Queen to C3 and now
Queen to H5 just threatening Checkmate
here G3 and the bishop to E5 attacking
the ax Queen here we have Queen to B3
and now Knight to C8 re-maneuvering the
Knight with Bishop to C1 and now Rook
the B8 attacking the queen here we have
Queen to A4 and now
uh you could play something like Rook to
B5 it defends both of the pawns but
alireza goes for the active Rook to D1
and how do you how do you uh react to
this Rook to D1 move uh you could always
trade and that could probably be the
best because uh but it's a very very
interesting line Rook captures Queen
captures and after King to G2 as the
white king is in check Rook now to B1
threatening the bishop but now you
ignore this and play Queen captures on
C6 and it's a force to draw it's
basically a draw by repetition Queen
captures Rook you're gonna capture the
Knight here with check and now Queen to
F5 check ensures a repetition uh you
can't really play G6 otherwise Queen
just captures here so I mean even that
that is a draw but probably we would see
something like a repetition here but
instead I have to Rook to D1 uh Rook to
D2 was played and now we have Rook
captures on F1 check team captures and
the Knight to B6 not rushing with Queen
characters and H2 first improving the
position of the Knight attacking
bogdon's Queen uh we have Queen captures
on C6 and only now now Queen captures an
H2 we have knighted the D3 and now Queen
to H1 with check King T2 and now Bishop
to D4 and it is incredibly difficult to
find the move here here Rook to D1 was
played and now uh feel free to pause the
video and try to figure out the only
move that wins for alireza while I give
you a couple of seconds
yeah
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
a very difficult to spot line and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to H5 with check it's
probably the first move you checked and
then you thought yeah no hey it's this
I'm just gonna keep looking but it is
actually this the problem is there's no
good square and even if you block with
the F3 then you allow Queen to H to with
check and now you're just gonna give up
a whole lot of Pawns king queen to G1
checking E2 you're gonna deliver another
check King T1 you're gonna pick up this
Pawn with check king T do another check
King E1 you're gonna pick up the F3 pawn
and now with the E4 Pawn being so weak
there's really no defense against uh
either Rook coming d8 for the moment
okay the the queen is guarding that
square but you could put the Rook to see
it and then get the Rook into the game
so there are many many uh ways to do
this it's not uh not that there's only
one way uh so it would be a very easy to
win this so here instead of a queen to
H5 check King the E1 was played but now
just rock see it this is how it is
against The Rook into the game with
Queen to B7 and now Queen to F3 and he
was in this position on move 41 uh that
bogdon Daniel Dak resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so tough loss for that who loses his
second game in a row but a great win for
alireza who lost his first round game to
Wesley so who now bounces back and is
back on 50 and here you resign uh what
do you play Rook d8 is coming there's
really no good way to stop this with the
queen being on B7
uh you could try something like Rook to
D2 to add more support to the F Pawn uh
but just rookie eight and that's it the
only way to defend the pawn here is to
play Rook to E2 but now ignite the C4
you take away the D2 Square from the
white king and queen to H1 will be
Checkmate there's no way to avoid this
and of course that's why dark resigned
after Queen to F3 uh but yeah a really
really well thought game uh that played
very creatively he pushed on the queen
side he had sort of a minority attack he
uh gave up upon to mess up as a spawn
structure then all it is I was sort of
able to give it back for something but
in the end it was the bluff that paid
off and got all the rest of the win uh
as the doc was low on time and he wasn't
able to work out all of the intricacies
of the position and that well that
basically resulted in his loss so very
nicely done by all it is that there is
probably one more game that we will
cover from this round as it's a it's a
very exciting one still happening as I'm
recording this so we'll see what happens
in that I'm sure you know which one I'm
talking about uh but yeah nice done by
alireza we'll see what happens in the
rest of the tournament I would like to
thank Edmund Freeman Evan Percy roshin
reptiles YouTube Lord of Bones and Mazin
elsarak for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day